at the highest level of Competitive
Gaming things are bound to go wrong this
is gonna be very difficult he doesn't
have like any time to work with the bomb
test can take five seconds alone he's
gonna go for it behind the fountain
Carrick is going to charge him down he's
gonna miss quite a few pistol shots
Kenny yes
it is a high stress environment where
players are always under a microscope
you can expect Pros to always be perfect
there are humans too so today we wanted
to take a look at the silliest mistakes
our favorite Pros have made in the
server across all Esports but before we
get into the video I have to remind you
guys for the first time to check out the
new the score Esports merged we have a
whole bunch of options check it out with
the link in the description below and
now let's get into it
despite g2's recent consistency issues
Miko is still one of the best mechanical
players in CS go but every once in a
while the best still miss I'm supposed
[Applause]
to show stuff
that's it for the non-cs go heads who
haven't gotten full body Shivers from
this clip a thousand times by now this
was supposed to be the shot that won G2
the second map of the Stockholm major
Grand finals that's right Nico whipped
what was likely the most important shot
of his career because after Nico missed
that shot GT to lost the map and of
course the major but what makes this
worse that Nico is bar for bar the best
deagle player of all time just maybe not
on nuke when his opponent's back is
turned
confident his own ability and now Nico
from Warehouse Sports One don't look at
the right way something about something
about nuke and uh deagle's and behind
the head shots uh Nico doesn't really
work all the time
the number one rule of Team games is
that communication is key and sometimes
even the best players have to learn that
the hard way
to run away a little bit of flash chases
didn't look great but in comes the
jewelry look at that what and he does
not have a way out for this one the
flash was already used here are your
puffers of time in comes proud and
they're gonna find their first kill the
game two base Made Alive as well the
chase Ford they got through them to
Baker Samsung Galaxy The Flash tornado
during the world's 2017 Grand finals
bang was under the impression his team
was about to fight in the dragon pit
little did he know they were actually
going in the complete opposite direction
to put the cherry on top bang used his
Flash and his alt to initiate leaving
him stranded and defenseless I think the
casters summarize the whole situation
best
to run away a little bit of flash chases
[Music]
and he does not have a way out for this
one the flash was already used
Apex Legends is a chaotic fast-paced
game where you need to manage a whole
lot of things at once but you would
never lose track of your opponents right
I'm going in I'm a bubble right away
there's a team
you got a little
bit in there
go right side Maybe
they got I altered in there I'm just
dead bro
wait there isn't a team in here
there isn't a team in there
uh awkward that that could be one of the
more Awkward Moments in algs history so
unfortunate for Esa during the algs
Esports Arena famously lost a 3v zero
when they Valkyrie altered into what
they thought was an enemy team after
dropping nades and ability is Left Right
and Center they quickly realized that no
one was actually there and then they
died because their screw-up left them
completely defenseless so unfortunate
for Esa just one barrel made them think
that there was an entire caustic team in
there and now everyone's scratching
their head
and CS go utility is key a single
well-placed flash smoke or Molly can
have ground changing impact just usually
the impact isn't felt the very second
the round starts both these teams were
expected to go through both these teams
mentally would have expected to go
through
what happened at the beginning around
for envious
welcome to the health
free might hold the record for fastest
nade damage in CS go history
unfortunately that damage was done to
his entire team while trying to throw
his nade away for an extra flash scream
bounced it off a light post and directly
into his team's faces maybe it's just
best if he sticks to one Taps there we
go here we go we do get to see ah you
saw that he's just trying to throw it
away
[Music]
that's why you throw it backwards
fighting games are all about precise
inputs and Flawless executions so aside
from getting up before a match is over
dropping a combo is one of the most
heartbreaking mistakes a player can make
Stan Brown House activation that was a
risky sweet Casino give away the
tournament here
[Music]
and that could beat the tournament Point
put gold on your Invitational Champion
drops combos happen pretty regularly in
high stress situations like these
unfortunately for Phenom this was about
the worst time to drop a combo in human
history Phenom and punk were playing for
150 000 one of the biggest prizes street
fighters ever seen if Phenom hid that DP
into Super he would have won the round
and evened things up instead Punk won
right then and there the drop of the
century
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone gets lost once in a while it's
just hard to believe that someone could
get lost in a game that has only one map
so far TSM has outmaneuvered
no quick silver sash
home he is shut down what is he doing in
game five of the 2019 LCS spring finals
it looks like TSM had a pretty solid
read over Team Liquid all they had to do
was play it cool and stick to the game
plan and everything was going smoothly
until Sven wandered off into the river
and basically single-handedly lost the
game so far TSM has outmaneuvered Sven
no quick silver sash he is down he is
shut down what is he doing
sven's over aggressive mistake gave Team
Liquid the opening they needed to rip
the game back from TSM and hoist their
third LCS trophy Team Liquid tie the
record it's three LCS titles in a row
oh the super teams
look sometimes you whiff an easy ability
it happens to everyone
when you whiff an easy ability twice
he's just been found out 10 seconds
remaining they're waiting for the EMP
engage but no one's in position
s
during a regular owl match the
Washington justices assassin whiffed a
somber alt now you might be wondering
why are the casters calling her e-sick
to investigate assassins for throwing it
was just one silly mistake right well
this was actually the second time
assassin whiffed one of the simplest
abilities in the entire game and the
first one was somehow way worse the same
rut despite upgraded a bunch of their
players here we go EMP catches no one
zerobody
zero 90 MP from assassin
all right guys now take this opportunity
to get serious with you understanding
the economy is important and nowhere is
it more important than CS go the economy
is key to the game and that includes
both saving when you need to and even
tossing a gun out of the map so your
enemies can't find it just be careful
where you throw it not because they just
can't hit the shots apparently okay
Dennis Law gets an AK
if this is a miracle round okay okay
this is smart I like this I like that
but if he gets it over that is it come
on
yeah oh wait hold on
[Laughter]
every entry on this list is going to be
a massive mistake that led to a team's
downfall some are just plain funny like
tossing it off out of the map only for
it to fall directly onto your opponent's
lap I don't think Dennis gonna be real
confused in the next round yeah it's
like oh wait up how do they have the off
heading back to screwing up simple
abilities we would be remiss if we did
not pay our respects to Kay jewels
canceled old one and the tower is a
dragon Advantage as well
ready to take the fight Flash over
canceled
wait
that was just canceled it in week one of
the 2018 EU LCS spring split the enemy
Ezreal was out of position looking super
juicy all cage real had to do was Flash
over to him and use what was possibly
the easiest fault in the game but after
casting his miles a heart alt cadral
immediately canceled it h2k lost the
team fight and eventually the game the
worst part was this was kadriel's second
ever Pro game and he never really lived
it down so I flash all to the Israel
because look at him he's completely
running it okay
and what happens here is I cancel my old
bags
I press re by accident
Trigger Discipline is a very underrated
skill in tactical Shooters holding your
fire can be the difference between
trading yourself and winning the round
but sometimes it can get you nothing at
all into a position forsaken has no clue
yeah this is a free kill
ing just got two kills in mid by the way
this kill well yes might be impactful oh
no he got too greedy he knew maybe net
was trying to be smart or maybe he was
getting too greedy either way the
disaster left everyone with their heads
in their hands
Jane just got two kills admit by the way
this kill well yes might be impactful
now he knew
simple is the greatest CS go player of
all time but even now and again the best
make mistakes map Point looking to be
confirmed oh no
nearly got knife simple of course trying
to push it through and it's in style a
match point against Team Liquid simple
tried to close it out with a cheeky
little knife on Nitro but it all
backfired with simple Whip and then it
got worse Nitro survived at low HP and
then went on to clutch the round and
then liquid made it to overtime and won
the map
and then the series
and then the grand finals and then the
IEM Grand Slam
oops the knife does cost
over time at that
well kiddos that's all we got today did
we miss one of your favorite Pros
mistakes let us know down in the comment
section below take care of yourself and
others and I'll see you in the next one
oh my God it's coffee
all right
all right that's embarrassed okay cool
thank you